author of The New York Times bestseller
of vengeance ease former Speaker of the
House Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich
Mr Speaker I just can't get over two
very important things here and that is
call me and and strux exoneration before
investigation and then a FISA memo that
they know Hillary bought and paid for
that's unverified by anybody that is
presented to a FISA Court and then they
don't tell the FISA Court that Hillary
bought and paid for the Russian lies
this is this is scary this is about
impact in the elections and the the
absolute integrity elections of this
country okay I think we're in George
Orwell territory this is why he wrote in
1984 he was terrified as he thought
about it about the power of a state to
begin to change history and to force
people to learn a fake history what
you're seeing here is every day I mean
you and I've talked to this every day
something new on rabble's something
falls out you see things you you know
who would have dreamed of Susan Rice
writing a memo to herself the way she
did fifteen days after a meeting and the
memo search sounds like it's a whitewash
memo it's a let me write this down so if
anybody ever asked it'll look correct
who would have imagined that you were as
we're learning more and more about the
former director of the CIA who certainly
sounds the more we learn about him like
he is the worst possible person to have
been charged the CIA during that period
and then every time we turn around there
is some new and I think very sobering
real revelation that doesn't fit the
world you and I thought we lived in you
know why would I read Susan Rice's memo
do I read into that oh there might be
something else and that's why the CIA
was done fifteen days later then I see
the involvement of Brennan and clapper
and then I look at what I just mentioned
about Comey exonerating there was no
vest this whole thing was rigged James
cows
right and then of course the FISA memo
and then the with look I continue to
tell people I think the most fascinating
single thing his strokes text message to
his girlfriend or vice versa that they
have to prepare this briefing for Comey
because Comey is going to brief Obama
and the president wants to know
everything now I never heard Comey say
he had briefed the president itíd States
and it strikes me that it's pretty easy
to say to the Congress you got to bring
Comey back in under oath how often did
you brief the president what did you
brief him about what was he concerned
about I mean we're really right at the
edge of Senator Howard Baker saying you
know the question is what did the
president know when when did he learn it
it really has taken the doors down to
Loretta Lynch right and then you hear
the President to Loretta Lynch who is
meeting with Bill Clinton the week that
his wife is going to be interviewed
interviewed being sort of a phony term
by Comey who's already been writing her
exoneration for two months before the
interview I mean you you couldn't make
this up as a serious novel because
there's so many people here that are
illegal every night nitrogens senior
people doing this every night on this
program I'm adding new information and
still because the story is it's getting
so big impacting so many people you kind
of have to build the bridge every night
so everybody understands what the new
information is but I want to stay
focused on this FISA for a second it was
unverified by diffusion GPS unverified
by the FBI
they knew Hillary bought and paid for it
and they didn't tell the FISA judge and
it wasn't done just once that they
attempted it in July they didn't get it
then they did it in October they got it
and then they were nude it three times
and the bulk of information that was
presented was the Clinton bought and
paid for dossier that they never
informed the judge about I mean if I'm
that FISA judge I'm calling those people
back in yesterday well look at this
point you also have to say when is the
Congress excuse me
when is the Congress gonna call in the
FISA judge what was the FISA judge
thinking why did he do it
Jimmy why didn't he ask these questions
I mean these are not it's not
implausible to say to the FBI gosh
where did you get this dossier from how
was it produced have you validate I mean
apparently the FBI validated nothing
they took this document they walked in
and they gave it to him without any
validation yeah unbelievable I agree
with you Mr Speaker I do believe this is
just last question historically I keep
saying it is so much bigger than
Watergate because of the use of the
highest levels the highest echelons in
intelligence the FBI the DOJ and the
absolute abuse of power the intelligence
weaponry we have and also the deception
to the FISA judge okay I believe this is
the clearest example we've had of to me
the danger of a deep state here you have
bureaucrats out of control with the
power of the government threatening I
think to undermine the entire process
including blocking excuse me blocking
Trump from being president and
protecting Hillary and it's only an
accident
I mean let's not kid herself a very
small number of people in Wisconsin
Michigan and Pennsylvania maybe in the
history or we would have learned nothing
about this well said all right mr.
speaker take care of the COFF I've had
it for a week myself feel better